Equivalence relations
are another kind
of binary relation
on a set which
play a crucial role in
mathematics and in computer
science in particular.
And they can also be explained
both in terms of digraphs
and in terms of axioms.
So let's begin with
a digraph explanation
of an equivalence relation.
And the kind of relation
that's an equivalence relation
is the relation of there being
a walk in both directions
between two vertices.
So if there's a walk between
vertex u and vertex v
and conversely there's a walk
from vertex v back to vertex u,
then u and v are said to
be strongly connected,
and strongly connected
is going to be
an example of an
equivalence relation.
So in terms of
the walk relation,
including 0-length walks, the
relation we're talking about is
u G* v and v G* u.
Now, as a property of
relations, this has a name.
It's called symmetry.
So a relation R on a set A is
symmetric if and only if a R
b implies b R a,
and the first remark
is that the strongly connected
relation is symmetric.
An equivalence relation is
a symmetric relation that
is transitive and reflexive.
And again, we have immediately
that the walk relation--
the mutual walk relation,
the two-way walk relation
or strongly connected
relation in a digraph
is an equivalence relation.
Because clearly if there's
two way paths between u and v
and between and v and w, then
there's one between u and w
by going for u to
v to w and back.
Likewise, there
is a length 0 walk
from any element to itself.
And by definition, strong
connectedness is symmetric.
So the strong connectedness
relation in any digraph
is an equivalence relation.
And the theorem is, conversely,
that any equivalence relation,
anything that's an
equivalence relation,
is the strongly connected
relation of some digraph.
The proof is trivial.
It's the strongly connected
relation of itself.
OK.
Some examples of
equivalence relations
to see why they're so basic is
that the most fundamental one
is equality.
Obviously, equality is symmetric
and reflexive and transitive,
and so it's an
equivalence relation.
Another one that we've
seen is congruence mod n,
which you could also check is
symmetric and transitive and
reflexive.
And finally, another
relation would
be that two sets
are the same size,
providing they're finite sets.
And another example would
be a bunch of objects
having the same color.
Two objects have the same color
is a relation among objects
that have color that is
symmetric and transitive and
reflexive, so it's an
equivalence relation.
Let's illustrate
some of these axioms
that we have in terms of graphs.
It can be helpful
to remember them.
So reflexive means that
when you look at a digraph,
it's reflexive when
there's a little self loop
from every vertex to itself.
So there's a length 1 path or
an edge from vertex to itself
in reflexive graphs.
Transitive means that whenever
you have two edges connecting
one vertex to another,
there's a path
of length 2 from
one place to another
that in fact is an edge from
that place to its target.
And of course as
we said, once there
is an edge wherever
there's a path of length 2,
it follows by
induction that there's
an edge wherever there's
a path of any length,
and that's what
transitive means.
Asymmetric means
that whenever you
have an edge from one vertex to
another there is no edge back.
So in particular,
if I have an edge
from this vertex to
that vertex in blue,
there is no edge that goes
back in the other direction.
Nor is there ever a self
loop in an asymmetric graph.
And finally, in a
symmetric graph,
wherever there's
an edge, there's
an edge that goes
back the other way.
So that can help
you maybe remember
what these properties mean.
Now again,
equivalence relations,
besides being
represented in terms
of the strongly connected
relation of a digraph,
can be represented in two
other very natural ways that
really explains
where they come from
and what their properties are.
So whenever you have a
total function f on a set A,
it defines an equivalence
relation on the set A. Namely,
if f is a total function
from domain A to codomain B,
then we can define a relation
we can call equivalence sub f
on the set A by the rule that
two elements are equivalents
of f if and only if they
have the same image under f--
they hit the same thing.
That is, A is equivalent
sub f to A prime if
and only if f of a is
equal to f of a prime.
And again, equivalence
sub f immediately
inherits the properties
of equality, which makes
it an equivalence relation.
And the theorem that we have is
that every relation R on a set
A is an equivalence relation
if and only if it in fact
is equal to equivalence
sub f for some function f.
Let's illustrate that.
We already remembered
that congruence mod n
can be understood as
equivalence sub f,
where the mapping is just
map things to remainders.
Two numbers are congruent
mod n if and only
if they have the same
remainder on division by n.
So map a number a to f of
k, equal its remainder,
and we have found
the equivalence sub f
representation of
congruence, which
is another way to
verify that congruence
is an equivalence relation.
Finally, whenever you
have a partition of a set,
you can define an
equivalence relation.
So a partition of a
set cuts up the set A
into a bunch of blocks
which are nonempty,
and every element is a
member of some block,
and the blocks don't overlap.
So in fact, every element is
a member of a unique block.
And that enables me to define
an equivalence relation on A
by the property that two
elements are in the same block.
In fact, that's the proof of the
previous representation theorem
in terms of a function that you
can map an element to the block
that it's in, in order
to see that the block
representation and
the equivalence sub f
representation are the same.
The proof in the
other direction,
that every equivalence relation
can be represented in this way,
is an exercise in
axiomatic reasoning,
and elementary one that we're
going to leave to a problem
and not do in this presentation.
So the theorem finally is that,
again, a relation R on a set
is an equivalence
relation if and only
if it is in fact the
being in the same block
relation for some partition.
And that is the story and
multiple ways of understanding
what equivalence relations are.